premier pied regardez ils ont envoyé
leurs pieds ça c'est qui ça alors ça
c'est alors déjà c'est un homme
mais c'est évident mais ouais c'est
assez Béatrice c'est bien
c'est les pieds de Béa je connais les
pieds parce que elle a pas voulu
raconter toute l'histoire de la voiture
[Rires]
deuxième paire de pied
regardez alors ça c'est alors déjà ce
sont les pieds sont les pieds malades
déjà est-ce que les gens étaient au
courant qu'ils allaient être pris en
photo
alors déjà il y a des poils hein
[Musique]
j'allais le dire mais tu as des pieds
tout fin par rapport à ta personne
de pédicure là qu'il va falloir faire
j'aurais peut-être de ma mère il a
envoyé un yep il a un Dong le frère sur
la tête de ma mère
[Applaudissements]
alors ce que je vois dans leur tête
j'entends ta voix
l'orteil
c'est vraiment vraiment
de l'argent ça non que le malade ça
mange tu vois c'est pas je te vois pas
du tout avec ce pied là je te vois pas
du tout
trois mois
pardon est-ce que c'est une vraie
question vraiment vraiment ça est-ce que
tu est-ce que vous aimez vos pièces
est-ce que tu es moi j'adore les pieds
tu as pas de complexes non alors Daniel
a dit elle a dit non je suis pas
d'accord
j'ai vu tes Ypres chéri je suis pas
d'accord ils sont pas mal aux pieds ils
sont bien alors regardez les pieds de
quelqu'un d'autre
ah bah c'est clair c'est clair c'est bon
du vernis moi aussi c'est toi c'est toi
Delphine bravo
[Applaudissements]
on va arrondir on dirait qu'il y a une
marque de champagne
ou alors gagner un voyage à mais
Guillaume Béatrice et Delphine on
déboqué et Raymond il a des pieds
alors là les frères sur la tête de ma
mère hameçon
[Applaudissements]
ce pied est un accident de la vie c'est
à qui ça mais qu'est-ce qui se passe il
y a des choses il y a des meufs
[Rires]
et je te promets j'en ai vu des pieds
mais
non il est même pas il est même pas
c'est on dirait un autre chose qu'un
pied
[Rires]
tu les as depuis longtemps comme ça
[Applaudissements]
je vais te présenter quelqu'un après il
faut lui présenter plusieurs personnes
je suis désolé alors regardez alors
regardez prochain yep je pense que
j'étais complètement
[Musique]
là vous allez voir là c'est les pieds
qui ont on voit qu'ils ont ils ont
bourlingué
c'est les pieds qu'on bourlinguer les
prochains ah maman
par contre c'est pas la même énergie
dans les deux pieds
non
mais le pied de gauche il veut pas faire
la photo
c'est fou mais il a des pieds
mais quel rapport
est-ce que tu les reconnais est-ce que
le pied gauche a été broyé dans l'action
de moto donc est-ce que vous
reconnaissez cette émission
regardez prochain pied regardez le
prochain film ça passe
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je suis partagé bah ça se fait pas de
juger le physique des gens moi aussi
j'ai pas des pieds j'ai des pieds que
j'aime pas mais parfois c'est agressif
ne nous prends pas par les sentiments
pas avec une histoire de dingue qui
t'est arrivé quand tu étais petite parce
que il y a aucun effort OK
je peux dire je peux dire la chose en
fait j'ai un vrai vrai problème avec mes
pieds mais vraiment merci
je vais te dire une chose Daniel je vais
te dire une chose d'abord je te
comprends et tes pieds on voit qu'ils
sont il faut que tu il faut justement
je refuse jamais rien Cyril vous me
connaissez pas non je pouvais pas
[Applaudissements]
et enfin le dernier up le dernier up
voilà
on dirait un orteil hein
et comme toi il est pas froid
il est pas tu vois
on m'a déjà proposé
[Applaudissements]